SHAWN: Good morning everyone.
My name is Shawn.
I'll be your TA this semester
for the class 10.213, Chemical
Engineering Thermodynamics.
I'm a fourth year PhD student
in the chemical engineering
department.
And my research is
actually related
to what you're going to
learn in this semester.
If you have any question
coming up, you can e-mail me.
And my email address is
Shawn-- S-H-A-W-N @mit.edu.
You can always come
to our office hour
if you have any questions.
I'll be happy to answer
any concerns and questions
that you have.
I really hope that we
can all learn together
throughout the semester,
tackling all the difficulty
and challenges in this class.
I hope you have a great
semester and a great learning
experience in 10.213.
MARZIEH: Hello, and welcome to
16.36, Communication Systems
and Networks.
My name is Marzieh,
and I will be your TA
throughout this semester.
About me, I'm a second year
PhD student in aeronautics
and astronautics department.
And I would like to help you if
you have any question related
to the course.
But I also want you to help me.
If there was anything
ambiguous, if you
had any problem
understanding what I explain
or related to my accent or
language barrier, please let me
know.
I will work on it
and try to fix it.
So the information that you
need is the office hours.
It will be on Mondays 3:00
to 4:00 PM in Room 33-422.
And if you have any
questions other than time,
please email me at
[AUDIO OUT] @mit.edu.
I will try to get back to
you as soon as possible.
OK.
So is there any question
related to this?